the world is awash with divisive
arguments conflict fake news victimhood
exploitation prejudice bigotry blame
shouting and minuscule attention spans
it can sometimes seem that we are doomed
to take sides be stuck in echo chambers
and never agree again it can sometimes
seem like a race to the bottom where
everyone is calling out somebody else's
privilege and vying to show that they
are the most hard done by person in the
conversation how can we make sense in a
world that doesn't I have a tool for
understanding this confusing world of
ours a tool that you might not expect
abstract mathematics I am a pure
mathematician traditionally pure maths
is like the theory of maths where
applied maths is applied to real
problems like building bridges and
flying planes and controlling traffic
flow but I'm going to talk about a way
that pure maths applies directly to our
daily lives as a way of thinking I don't
solve quadratic equations to help me
with my daily life but I do use
mathematical thinking to help me
understand arguments and to empathize
with other people and so pure maths
helps me with the entire human world but
before I talk about the entire human
world I need to talk about something
that you might think of as irrelevant
school
maths factors of numbers we're going to
start by thinking about the factors of
30 now if this makes you shudder with
bad memories of school maths lessons I
sympathize because I found school maths
lessons boring too but I'm pretty sure
we're going to take this in a direction
that is very different from what
happened at school so what are the
factors of 30 well they're the numbers
that go into 30 maybe you can remember
them we'll work them out it's 1 2 3 5 6
10 15 and 30 it's not very interesting
it's a bunch of numbers in a straight
line we can make it more interesting by
thinking about which of these numbers
are also factors of each other and
drawing a picture a bit like a family
tree to show those relationships so 30
is going to be at the top like a kind of
great grandparent 6 10 and 15 go into 35
goes into 10 and 15 2 goes into 6 and 10
3 goes into 6 and 15 and 1 goes into 2 3
& 5 so now we see that 10 is not
divisible by 3 but that this is the
corners of a cube which is I think a bit
more interesting than a bunch of numbers
in a straight line we can see something
more here there's a hierarchy going on
at the bottom level is the number 1 then
there's the numbers 2 3 & 5 and nothing
goes into those except 1 and themselves
you might remember this means they're
prime at the next level up we have 6 10
and 15 and each of those is a product of
two prime factors so 6 is 2 times 3 10
is 2 times 5 15 is 3 times 5 and then at
the top we have 30 which is a product of
3 prime numbers 2 times 3 times 5 so I
could redraw this diagram using those
numbers instead so we see that we've got
2 3 & 5 at the top we have pairs of
numbers at the next level and we have
single element
at the next level and then the empty set
at the bottom and each of those arrows
shows losing one of your numbers in the
set now maybe it can be clear that it
doesn't really matter what those numbers
are in fact it doesn't matter what they
are so we could replace them with
something like a B and C instead and we
get the same picture so now this has
become very abstract the numbers have
turned into letters but there is a point
to this abstraction which is that it now
suddenly becomes very widely applicable
because a B and C could be anything for
example they could be three types of
privileged rich white and male so then
at the next level we have rich white
people here we have rich male people
here we have white male people then we
have rich white and male and finally
people with none of those types of
privilege and I'm going to put back in
the rest of the adjectives for emphasis
so here we have rich white non male
people to remind us that there are
non-binary people we need to include
here we have rich non-whites male people
here we have non rich white male people
rich non-whites non male non rich whites
non male and non rich non-whites male
and at the bottom with the least
privileged non rich non-whites non male
people we have gone from a diagram of
factors of 30 to a diagram of
interaction of different types of
privilege and there are many things we
can learn from this diagram I think the
first is that each arrow represents a
direct loss of one type of privilege
sometimes people mistakenly think that
white privilege means all white people
are better off than all non-white people
some people points at super rich black
sports stars and say see they're really
rich white privilege doesn't exist but
that's not what the theory of what white
privilege says
it says that if that super-rich
Sportster had all the same
characteristics but they were also white
we would expect them to be better off in
society there is something else we can
understand from this diagram if we look
along a row if we look along with a
second to top row where people have two
types of privilege we might be able to
see that they're not all particularly
equal for example rich white women are
probably much better off in society than
poor white men and rich black men are
probably somewhere in between so it's
really more skewed like this and the
same on the bottom level but we can
actually take it further and look at the
interaction between those two middle
levels because rich non-white non men
might well be better off in society than
poor white men think about some extreme
examples like Michelle Obama Oprah
Winfrey they're definitely better off
than poor white unemployed homeless men
so actually the diagram is more skewed
like this and that tension exists
between the layers of privilege in the
diagram and the absolute privilege that
people experience in society and this
has helped me to understand why some
poor white men are so angry in society
at the moment because they are
considered to be high up in this cuboid
of privilege but in terms of absolute
privilege they don't actually feel the
effect of it and I believe that
understanding the root of that anger is
much more productive than just being
angry at them in return
seeing these abstract structures can
also help us switch contexts and see
that different people are at the top in
different contexts in our original
diagram rich white men were at the top
but if we restricted our attention to
non men we would see that they're here
and now the rich white non men are at
the top so we could move to a whole
context of women and our three types of
privilege could now be rich white and
cisgendered remember that cisgendered
means that your gender identity does
match the gender you were assigned at
birth so now we see that rich white sis
women occupy the analogous situation
that rich white men did in broader
society and this has helped me
understand why there is so much anger
towards rich white women especially in
some parts of the feminist movement at
the moment because perhaps they are
prone to seeing themselves as
underprivileged relative to white men
and they forget how over privilege they
are relative to non-white women we can
all use these abstract structures to
help us pivot between situations in
which we are more privileged and less
privileged we're all more privileged
than somebody and less privileged than
somebody else for example I know and I
feel that as an Asian person I'm less
privileged than white people because of
white privilege but I also understand
that I am probably among the most
privileged of non-white people and this
helps me pivot between those two
contexts and in terms of wealth I don't
think I'm super rich I'm not as rich as
the kind of people who don't have to
work but I am doing fine and that's a
much better situation to be in than
people who are really struggling maybe
are unemployed or working at minimum
wage I perform these pivots in my head
to help me understand experiences from
other people's points of view which
brings me to this possibly surprising
conclusion that abstract mathematics is
highly relevant to our daily lives and
can even help us to understand and
empathize with other people my wish is
that everybody would try to understand
other people more and work with them
together rather than competing with them
and trying to show that they're wrong
and I believe that
abstract mathematical thinking can help
us achieve that thank you
[Applause]